Німеччина має імідж країни з добре функціонуючою системою соціального захисту.
Прожити на "соціалку" у ФРН справді можна.
При цьому мало хто з німців на цьому спекулює, і
і нині рівень безробіття в країні найнижчий з часів возз’єднання Німеччини -
менше п’яти відсотків.
У ФРН є різні види соціальної допомоги: від допомоги літнім людям
до підтримки дітей і біженців.
Але класична "соціалка" в Німеччині - це допомога з безробіття.
Розрізняють два види такої допомоги.
Перший - для тих, хто відносно недавно втратив роботу.
Вони отримують 60 відсотків, а якщо є діти,
то 67 відсотків від cуми останнього заробітку.
Право на такі виплати діє від шести місяців до двох років -
залежно від віку і страхового стажу безробітного.
Якщо протягом цього часу не вдасться знайти нову роботу,
ви переходите у категорію так званих "довгострокових" безробітних
і можете розраховувати на соціальну програму Hartz IV.
Якщо ви живите один, то держава виплачує вам
424 євро на місяць.
А якщо з партнером, який теж без роботи,
по 382 євро на кожного.
Діти безробітних отримують по 245 євро на місяць
до п’яти років, а з шести до тринадцяти по 302 євро.
Крім того, держава оплачує медстраховку, оренду житла та комунальні ватрати.
Соціальне житло має обмежений метраж: до 50 квадратних метрів на 1 людину,
до 65 на двох і так далі
з прибавкою 10-15 "квадратів" на кожного наступного члена родини.
Вартість оренди, яка покривається, теж обмежена залежно від регіону і міста.
У Мюнхені, де житло одне з найдорожчих у ФРН,
держава покриє вдвічі більшу суму, ніж приміром,
у Східній Німеччині.
Безробітних прискіпливо контролюють, вони мають бути постійно на зв’язку.
До них у будь-який час можуть прийти з перевіркою умов проживання.
Виїзд за кордон обмежений -
лише після погодження з куратором з Jobcenter
і не більше.
За безпідставні постійні незгоди на запропоновану роботу та інші порушення
соцдопомогу можуть суттєво скоротити.
Спершу на 30 відсотків на строк три місяці.
Якщо це не діє, то вже на 60 відсотків,
а потім соцвиплати на три місяці повністю скасовуються,
хоча залишається соціальна допомога у негрошовій формі.
Втім, у листопаді цього року такі скорочення пільг
за недотримання умов надання соцвиплат
були визнані неконституційними.
Поки не ухвалять нові законодавчі положення,
суд зобов’язав центри зайнятості
уважніше враховуват обставини тих, хто потребує допомогу.
Інший важливий вид соціальної допомоги
у Німеччині - так звані "дитячі гроші".
Ця допомога призначається кожній дитині, яка легально проживає в Німеччині,
навіть якщо це діти іноземців.
Виплати становлять приблизно 200 євро щомісяця.
Також малозабезпечені пенсіонери, щомісячна пенсія яких
нижче восьми сотень євро, мають право
на соцдопомогу - 300-400 євро.
Крім того, держава допомагає їм також із витратами на житло і комуналку.
Серед отримувачів соціальної допомоги є ще особлива категорія громадян -
це люди, які не можуть піклуватися самі про себе
внаслідок хвороби, інвалідності або немічності
Приміром, серед іншого держава допомагає їм
з оплатою послуг доглядальників.
Великі кошти Німеччина витрачає
і на допомогу біженцям.
Суми залежать від віку, сімейного стану і від того, де саме живе біженець.
Приміром, якщо це одинак без родини і мешкає
у таборі для біженців,
то 135 євро на місяць, а якщо поза табором, то вже майже втричі більше.
А от іноземці, яку шукають у Німеччині роботу,
не мають права на соцдопомогу.
Тож якщо хтось легально приїхав з України до ФРН у пошуках роботи,
він не може претендувати на жодну соцдопомогу
і мусить розраховувати лише на свої власні заощадження.